foreign
comes from Peter in California and I'm
told by our producer James this is a
real question I just want to preface
that we didn't make this up Peter says
I'm a citizen of California and I just
thought of an ingenious way any U.S
adult citizen may be able to come up
with millions of dollars and I want to
see if you think it would be a dumb idea
can I stop right there yes
probably a dumb idea
well let's let's hear his hypothetical a
million dollar uh ingenious scheme the
idea is to build a great credit score
then open a credit card with all 4 236
banks in the U.S you would already need
to be making payments on a house and own
a car so you wouldn't need credit
anymore then you simp simply max out all
4 236 credit cards by cash advancing to
the max on every card with how how many
ever ATMs it takes this would leave you
with almost 22 million dollars in Cold
Hard Cash if for example the Max on each
card was five thousand dollars you would
just need to make sure the bank your
house is in doesn't have a credit card
on it I understand you can't be
criminally prosecuted for Consumer Debt
and they can't even come after you at
all after six years but they can try
pushing a lawsuit against you is this a
dumb idea or truly ingenious
if anyone wonders how's our Public
Schools doing these days
let this be exhibit a for not great are
they teaching in California
this is the result of uh teach to the
test right here guys teach to the test
do you think this is like an 18 year old
or is this like an older guy who hatched
another plan in all honesty we get a lot
of grief for oversimplifying things and
for uh you know talking down like down
to P like we just make everything so
simple this is why why questions do we
get
these are questions so we're gonna try
to explain again we are not experts on
the banking industry and on credit card
you know how the inner workings of that
but I'll tell you what we do know that's
what we do know
um this won't work even if you wanted it
to not even close
and if it did you wouldn't want it so
number one all four thousand two hundred
thirty six Banks I'm just using Peter's
number I don't know if that's how many
banks there are they few only a few of
them actually issue cards and many banks
that do issue cards issue them through
other Banks they're a pass through so
All 4 236 banks in the U.S are not
issuing credit cards they might issue a
line of credit to a particular person or
they might issue a debit card that's
just your own money so that's problem
number one number two
very few cards if any will let you take
out the full cash advance amount and so
if your credit limit's five grand you
can't take out five grand in cash
advance it might be like fifteen hundred
bucks there you go and
after you took out the fourth card or
the fifth card every time you take out a
credit card they pull your credit they
run a credit report at some point the
bank's gonna go uh no this guy's got 48
cards open this guy's trying to open a
bunch of cards his total a bit his
ability to get himself into trouble is
now gone twenty thousand twenty five
thousand thirty thousand thirty five up
to 22 million
and here's the even stupider part that
cash advance that you took out on that
card has a higher interest rate so even
if you hypothetically had 22 million
dollars in cash you now owe 20 something
percent on 22 million dollars but he's
saying I don't care after six years I'll
go away
oh boy well aside from integrity and and
fraud this is fraught with stupidity if
nothing else
just get a freaking job dude and I do
like trying to hack the system that you
use the word fraught fraught
that's that's some angry Boston right
I've been hanging out with Ken Coleman
all those Ten Dollar Words finally
rubbed off on me man okay well hey hey
good job uh I mean literally like
good job yeah
um if you use this kind of mental
gymnastics on something for good you
could be like the nest the next Elon
Musk exactly and and
senators and House Representatives
can we please get serious about fixing
the U.S education system because it's
it's it's dysfunctional and the U.S
credit system and debt system which is
the most marketed product in the world
and America is number one at debt like
no other we're the best I just heard a
clip from a Dax Shepard's podcast and
one of the actors on there was like I'm
in New Zealand you there's no credit
score like we can't I came to America
and they're like here's debt you need to
take out debt you got to build a credit
score and even he was like this is
insane why are we do so he's like I just
keep spending because they tell me I
need to spend it's he doesn't even
understand it hey uh we are the best at
that America's number one at a lot of
things and debt is at the top of that
list so hey gold gold stars way to go
America oh my goodness hey that's uh job
security for us John we'll be helping
out we'll be helping out Peter when he
calls in and says I'm 22 million dollars
in credit card debt please help I
thought it was going to be an awesome
scheme all right you can't go inside of
a restaurant for the next 1400 years
Peter well the good news John this
sounds like it could have been your idea
15 years ago 100 that's hey this is why
I'm so sad because I've actually sat
down on a piece of paper been like hey I
think what if I think I've got a plan